[Music]
today I thought we would do kind of a
fun beam and we would look at endgame
Catholics tactic colonel normally
associated with the opening or the
middle game but they exist in endgame
just as much and I brought a book here
called endgame tactics and I dug it out
especially for today but then I ended up
finding so many examples in chess base
and online I didn't take anything from
this book yes yeah it's nice thick and
it can last you probably several years I
haven't gone through much of it but some
okay fair enough
this is the first problem this is
actually one that I've known for a long
time I think it's really cool this is
White's to move if you've seen it before
let others try and figure it out but
white to move find the best continuation
if you think you have an answer please
raise your hand
all right Ashish what you think yeah so
King c-4 is the correct first move you
want to make sure that blacks King is
just kind of stuck on a four and now the
question is what does the result going
to be with with perfect play I'm asking
what is the results going to be is it
going to be a draw is black can black
win can light win so it's important to
kind of see I had what's going to happen
it turns out white is winning in just a
few moves and King c4 is actually the
start of force mates even though black
took up two pawns and what's going to
happen is black is basically in
perpetual with long black only legal
move is d5 white will play King c5 black
has to play d4 again only legal move and
now we go back and if we know this it's
kind of the finals live long position
black is forced to self-destruct and
yeah a cheese King c2
Oh in the earlier position well let's
see what's going to happen then we'll
come back to that here at Black has to
play b3 and then simply mate and it's
one of these like weird moments where
especially when there's so few pieces on
the board black found himself in a
situation where every move he played was
basically self-destructing now let's go
back because you're asking about King c2
oh you're thinking c3 uh-huh Oh King c3
yeah I think it's the same thing yeah
King c3 or king c5 and after before
again a legally legal moves you play
King c4 and still winning it's very
important that you start with key c4 as
any other move that black king can
escape so any questions about this
hopefully pretty simple we can move on
okay now I have a slightly more
difficult problem and this came from
like a database I have on n game studies
and this is obviously a composed
position but I thought kind of the
process of figuring out the forcing line
and figuring out how light wins is
really instructive and it really kind of
tests you to like your full kind of
length of calculation and this is a
difficult problem for me so I think what
we'll do I'll let you guys kind of stare
at this for a little bit in confusion
and then we'll look at the first few
moves and then we'll try and figure out
the final idea but I was really confused
when I first saw this so just just think
quietly and maybe after about 30 seconds
and we'll we'll be stuff whites to move
and win
c6 or a - okay so nice hc6 is an
interesting try however I believe after
King take a three you're in a little bit
of trouble because Lacs about to Queen
and it's kind of hard to stop
you can't play rook v1 and the Queen a
one Queen comes with check and this is a
big problem if we notice in the starting
position black has two big threats black
threatening to take the rook and also
Queen with check so we kind of have to
be creative in the way we approach this
ya know
all right I'll give you guys the first
move my teaching check you're right you
should have said something kind less
nice see two kind of a confusing move
because you're checking the King with
the rook but the rook can be taken but
you're sacrificing the rook for good
reason as we'll see so so you take be
five and let's slow down
so King v3 is like the natural try
unfortunate king D 3 I believe just
needs to draw after like a one queen
maybe even black has winning chances
take take you're not going to win this
is like yep
so night a1 is just an incredible move
and you're giving away the bishop and
normally when you give away so much
material yeah you want it to check the
king - right
normally when you just have king at
night no checkmate is possible but in a
position like this there is there's some
issues for black because as pawns take
away squares from the king so King c3
which is kind of same idea from the
earlier problem b4 now where should the
King goat King c4 King c2 one vote for
King c4 few votes for King seated King
see two very important if you play King
c4 then King B - so you can't let the
King escape king c2 and again we see
black only has one move be three King
c3b to only move and second mate why
so I don't know how the composer came up
with this problem because it's just
ridiculous but maybe he I don't probably
spend a lot of time maybe yeah I took a
took a simpler idea and made it bit more
complex now I would be really interested
to see it like if I had this in an
online game and I was black I would let
my time run out and see what happens
because normally King and Knight is
insufficient mating material and usually
a few flag in this position it would the
game would be declared a draw but I
think there are exceptions to that rule
and it's a sort of tournament game if
you can kind of show that maid is coming
men will be given the way it was so I've
never been in the situation so if black
flagged foul I think it should be
declared a win for white yeah but there
are rules where like if you flag but
your opponent has insufficient mating
material then it's it's declared a draw
but this is one of those weird
exceptions
anyway any questions about this kind of
weird complex not very practical but I
thought it's very interesting and
creative yep yes if you don't play
nicely too if you don't go into that
exact line then I think it's either
winning for black or at least wrong yeah
okay so let's move on I want to show
some more practical tactics which can
maybe happen in your games I don't see
this position happening in your game
anytime soon
maybe yeah
so I want to start with just some simple
concepts and then we'll kind of build
off them and get more complex so the
first one really standard ideas should
be relatively straightforward give you
guys a moment to glance at it this is
white to move and win okay yeah yeah
rokay chase and the idea is you want to
promote the pond and you also are ready
if black takes upon to simply check and
pick up the rook so this is the classic
tactic where blacks king is misplaced
black would rather have the key on g7
where Rock h8 wouldn't be possible but
let's move on simple a this position
kind of similar idea white wants to
promote the pawn YC moving win
okay Abbi rook check okay rook ta check
very good because you're clearing the
applause for promotion Black has no time
to take it when the King moves you just
promotes easy way so it makes sense
things will get a bit more complicated
actually going to give you a very
similar position but this time it's
black to move and there's times in chess
where you're the one executing the
tactics or when you're on the kind of
receiving and your defensive end or you
have to realize your opponent's catch
the ideas and defend so this is a
defensive problem black to move King g7
everyone agree I hope so King g7 is
maybe counterintuitive at first because
you're moving away from the pawn but
it's actually the only drawing move
actually I take that back
okay one is also drawing but eventually
you have to play King g7 because now
there's no more like rook check or rook
going all the way and setting up the
skewer if you walked towards the pond
this would end pretty tragically for
black after rook h8 and now this is
actually kind of a theoretical known
position where if you're white there's
no way to win White's best try is to
walk the King all the way towards the
rook and then all the way up but the
problem is that the White King has no
shelter so even if white gets his King
let's say the King comes all the way
over attacks the rook the rook moves up
taking attacks it again rook moves back
King walks all the way up to this
position then you can just start
checking and the King has an over time
okay so let's move on getting creedy's
very quickly
okay so this is more I guess conceptual
where let's say you're playing white and
the objective is to figure out if you
can win or is it just a draw so I'll
give you guys a little bit of time to
think
then we'll take a poll I'll ask if the
positions winning for white or drawn and
we'll see what the breakdown is alright
let's take a poll and in this case you
might have to use your intuition but
we'll see how many people think like can
win being up to funds okay couple people
how many people think black can draw
most people most people are correct this
is a dead drop and the reason is
actually pretty simple for black all
black has to do is keep the king on each
seven and there's no way for white to
make progress now White's best try is to
basically go kamikaze with the H pawn
play h5 yeah questions we will get to
that that's going to be the next few
examples it will definitely get that
decision like so if the King walks like
to b7 then the ropes that starts
checking and then the King would have to
go come all the way back to get out of
checks and that's that's one issue for
whites so if I were white the best try
would be to play h5 and let's say let's
say Blastoise weights and then go for h6
and then you're really hoping that black
takes the pot so then you have rookie
chase and you win
but if black plays King h7 there is no
way for for white to make progress the
only piece that can really move is the
king the King can't accomplish anything
on its own
[Music]
oh so this way then the rook will move
here and then you attack me again I'll
move back so yeah your King could dance
around like your King has a lot of
squares on the board but essentially the
black rook will just stay on a file and
eventually the game will be drawn do 250
moves or if light just gives away the
pawns it'll just be a draw so yeah the
next few positions we're going to look
at a different pawn than H pawn okay
we're going to do the same thing I'll
let you guys think for at least 30
seconds and then we'll take another poll
can light win with the Jeep on or as a
physician going to be a draw
alright let's let's take the poll
how many people would I think light can
win so the majority think like can win
how many people think it's a draw one
person well I think it's as broad - this
is absolutely dead job and maybe it's a
little bit unfair because if the H pawn
seemed dead drawn but maybe the Jeep on
there's more hope but it's really just
the same same thing the King's going to
stay on g7 and White's best hope is to
try and sacrifice the Jeep on go for g5
black and wait and go for g6 and all
black has to do is not take the Jeep on
just leave the King on g7 keep moving
the rook and of course if black blunders
and does take upon then there is where
ta check
so it's really the same thing if the
King comes to be seven is continual
checks oh if the King comes in front of
the Jeep on like this then the rook will
just keep waiting and then the King will
just stay stationary I can try okay so
now we're going to go and look at the
next example which kind of predicted is
can white win with the S pawn now keep
thinking stay silence give you guys 30
seconds to a minute and then we'll take
the same polkan lightwind alright let's
take the poll how many people think like
can win most people everyone how many
people think is to draw the same person
think thinks it's a draw unfortunately
this time white is winning so most of
you are correct and white is winning
because a spawn is close enough to the
center to actually drive the black king
where we want it and it's going to use
the same kind of tactical ideas as we
saw previously so the winning plan for
white is actually very simple just walk
upon to f6 we don't even need our King
to really play a role in the position
pawn s6 or quanta for first row k1 plus
five okay to pawn s6 and it turns out
the King has no we're good to go it has
what few different legal moves all of
them run into something bad if King to
the six rank so King to Augusta King g6
or King h6 there's rook to the eighth
rank check and promoting pawn if King f7
we have the same type of tactic as we
saw earlier rogue h8 with the same
skewer
and okay of course if King h7 there's no
more of those rook tactics but then we
just simply push the pot and then we're
promoting that fun and if black wanted
to be annoying he could check the King
for a limited number of moves and
eventually the King will run over and
black can design so any questions about
that so if you're going to take
something away from this you want to
remember that if you have kind of this
setup on the Queen side your pawn has to
be on the F file or closer to the center
if it's a G pawn or an H pawn and lock
and draw so hopefully that makes sense
to everyone let's move on okay I hope
you guys aren't sick of like this rook
pawn versus rook I'm trying to make it
exciting that's not it okay so I'm gonna
give you guys one last puzzle involving
kind of a similar situation this is
white to move and I just want to explain
a backstory I give this puzzle to one of
my friends
several years ago my friend was rated
about 2000 and it took him maybe 15 to
20 minutes and then he just gave up and
his rating was 2000 I think it was
because he just did not understand 10
games or his mind like couldn't wrap
around the like endgame concepts or any
game tactics so in this position white
is winning it's White's moving win but
if you don't know the tactical idea is
it could be hard to solve so I'll give
everyone a little bit of time to think
ok let's start with Ashish
so Rick h6 check is a very very
important move and this is the only
winning move and the idea is that the
king either has to go to the fifth rank
where it's obviously skewered or the
seventh rank which is maybe a better try
let's say it goes to d7 someone else
other than the shish wipe to move and
win yep yeah just work 88 and it's the
same tactic alai Diaz before only the
rook is coming from h6 rather than eight
and you take advantage of the fact that
you have the threat of promoting and the
pawn can't be taken and the king is not
close enough and if we go back it was
kind of unfortunate for black the e6
square is actually a really bad square
for the King and so is the a five square
for the rook because when the rook
checks like the the skewer possibilities
combined with the fact that the King was
just too much in the center where it
can't be close enough to the pond and it
can't run towards the other edge of the
board to survive so so if it was on f6
in this position I believe would be
drawn because after rook age 67 there's
no more of that same tactic so any
questions move on all right
now we're going to switch gears a little
bit oh okay not really
I lied we have one more like really kind
of complex problem and I came across
this problem kind of doing my own like
self-study and when I like solve tough
puzzles I solved from a book called
imagination in chess and they have like
very very difficult puzzles and they're
rated from zero stars to four stars and
just to give you kind of a example a
zero star problem usually takes me on
average about five minutes to solve four
star problem could take me days to solve
so
this problem is actually a zero-star
problem got bring this really it's a
book imagination in chess so I just took
it from here it's like within the first
hundred problems of the book um I forget
I've had the book for a long time so
this is a this is actually black to move
I think we'll look at it from whites
perspective though so I don't want to
confuse people with notation so bucks
about to promote the deep on blacks also
a pop on and the question becomes how
does black managed to win this position
and I'm kind of debating whether to give
you guys a chance to find a move or just
to show it to you I think I'll let you
guys think for maybe about a minute and
then we'll kind of walk through the
solution so clocks moving
that's the exact solution Wow very good
you've probably solve this quicker than
me deserve a prize of some sorts yeah
for those of you get those of you who
didn't follow g4 and what black is going
to do is sacrifice the kingside plunge
to open up the second rank as pretty
like genius idea that you kind of have
to know the fundamental tactic to find
like this more complex combination so
white is pretty much obliged to take
then each three again white really has
no choice but to take and then black can
take on s2 threatening to Queen after
King T guess - it's basically the same
simple ideas before rook h1 in this case
winning the the white rook which will
eventually allow back to win the game
it's a little bit deceiving I it seems
like blacks self-destructing but it's
all for a purpose and that's why you
really want to know kind of your like
foundational tactics so you can find
more complex things like this and I
don't think there's any other way for
blacks win like black hats to play g4
now let's really no other option so okay
we can move on and now we're going to
kind of switch teams
let's move on there are some Queen
endings I actually wanted to look at
what's called seven heaven and again
we're going to kind of start basic we're
going to look at some very kind of
foundational puzzles which you guys
should all come as grasp and then we'll
go on to more complex complex positions
so this is white to move and win should
be pretty straightforward on basically
forced me can West Brook a7 yeah
basically just making sure the rooks are
far enough away from the king so you're
going to deliver mate
with rook h8 or rook a8 and a king has
no defense and the black rooks on force
they are out of place to defend - so
this is a problem that even though
blacks up to pawns white just has a the
more active rooks
or the more effective rooks and this is
a very common scenario especially in a
lot of end games and especially when
there are still rooks on the board you
want your rooks usually on your
opponent's 7th rank or if you're black
the second rank and idea is to cut off
your phone's King and sometimes when
material but sometimes create meeting
Nets so we're going to see more examples
of this yep so this is another example
like you should kind of familiarize
yourself with these different scenarios
this is white to move and well the
question is can white win or can white
draw or is white losing
okay anyone thinks white is losing
anyone thinks it's going to be a draw
anyone think like can win okay most of
you are I think all of you are right
that this was just a dead draw
White has nothing better than just
perpetual check because white doesn't
really have time to set up mate his last
threatening multiple mates against White
King so what will end up happening is
let's say King h8 even take here check
here and this is actually important that
you have to check with the right rook
here if you check with the wrong rook
then I believe you could be losing you
have to play rook gf7 if you play rook
es7 then the king escapes
here and then the bishop can move
backwards and unfortunately then whites
losing so you actually have to be
careful as white that you don't check
with the wrong rook and really this rook
should stay stationary this should
just be locked 97 and you're really just
moving this rook between these 3 squares
question oh that's interesting I have a
bad feeling about this because both of
your roofs are undefended and I would
wonder if there's not just a way to fork
one of the King like one of the rooks in
the king actually at the the Queen could
land on t6 forcing King Jiwon and then
boom and then that it's winning I
believe for her luck that might be
possible there might be a fortress sir
that's why I said it might be winning
but I don't get into that so yeah I just
don't like there's no reason for white
to take a risk and take on h3
so okay let's move on
another example this is white to move
and it's very important to notice that
of course you have threats on the
seventh rank with like rooks e7 check
the black is also threatening the very
deadly rook e1 so in chess especially in
n games you want to be aware of your
active site but also your pawns a
quickly turns out that white is the
first one to strike because it's white
smooth and white actually has forcemeat
here so give you guys a chance to think
and try and find us okay yeah
67 the king has two options as king d8
then just made one so King to you okay
now again the king has two options let's
start with King a so R okay seven double
check can be it over okay yeah Rick a is
is actually the fastest okay I made it
longer but made in two would be rook HB
7 and then like this mate so the very
important element here is a spaceship on
G 2 even though it's far away from the
action usually if you want to mate with
two works on the seventh you need like
an extra defender in this case the
bishop does a nice job defending the
eight square and actually if we go back
and look at the other line the bishop
can also be useful after King CH because
what's uh what's the key move here yeah
Bishop h3 a forcing okay black can't
block with really anything and it's King
d8 and we just made question no okay
let's move on okay this is a really cool
one oops let's not give away the
solution this is white to move maybe you
guys saw the first move but it's kind of
the same question should White's just go
for a draw because there is an easy
perpetual check with just the rook
moving back and forth or can light a
free win and I will tell you guys right
away that liking me
I'll tell you white can win so it's
basically white to move and win you have
to try and find the winning idea rook
h2h hd7 okay King h8 never mind okay
Brook hd7 is a move that was just said
oh you want to take the pawn this you
don't want to do because then the Queen
will have time to come back and you've
actually lost your ability to like
perpetual check the King and black
should be winning this from as far as I
can see so actually let's go back
because rook hg 7 is not the right first
move which should actually allow you
guys to find the right first move which
is rook SG 7 and now we want to force
the King towards the center gives worked
in a set up some mating ideas so after
King f8 we take on c7 threatening me or
actually threatening both the c8 and
rock h8
so yeah you'll see there's going to be a
pattern that emerges because the King is
pretty much forced to just move back so
only defense for black and then very
cleverly we just come back check then we
take the b7 pawn and this is kind of an
interesting example of a window where
you kind of do like this repetitive
process but you gradually make progress
until all the pawns are gone all the
pigs are gone you take on a 7 the
Queen's attacked you're threatening a
few different mating ideas and black is
forced to give away the Queen if he
wants to not get made and then it's just
a winning ending so Queen take take and
Black has no chance so I thought this
was a really cool example because I
wasn't really that expected from just
glancing at it that you could just keep
checking the King taking upon checking
the King taken upon until you went the
Queen
but it's one of these kind of patterns
that you should kind of acquire over
time so that if it happens in the game
you should identify it okay so let's
move on another seven have an example I
want to hide that maybe you saw the
first move this is black to move made in
five and of course you have your rooks
on this on the second in this case wipes
up a ton of material about to promote
another queen what to do
so take a little bit of time and try and
calculate okay so I heard a couple of
different suggestions for the first move
let's walk through it because I did hear
the right answer and it's very important
that black doesn't play h3 immediately
h3 is a key idea but if you play right
now
then Queen take e5 and whites actually
defending and just winning this position
is h2 is guarded so you have to check
first work h2 for King g1 and then play
ref you to get your rook to g2 and h2
and then you play h3 because now you
have a maid in one threat how is this
made five good question um white has a
weird way of delaying the me I can play
like 92 or Bishop c5 or queen a7 and put
something on g1 but then it'll be made
so like a fish at c5 we made like this
and in this case it was extremely
important that black had the H pawn
fahren under dance so as we saw last
time another example with the bishop the
bishop was key in mating in this case H
pawn is necessary for blacks to achieve
the mate and usually the cases you have
to defend one of the rooks with another
piece to make a check okay I think we
may have gone through all the seven
heaven examples you don't have to apply
yet we still have like ten minutes left
so I saved some like fun problems for
them actually I lied we didn't get
through all of the seven has an example
this is a final one I like to give this
one to students because it's really just
to test their kind of mental agility and
to see if they can come up with the
Knights idea this was black to move I'm
not going to say flax winning but I will
say that there is a best move here for a
black and if you're trying to play for a
win you should definitely play this move
okay yeah Cory rook a 287 so I know like
your thought process could you seven
heaven but if you're black you want to
do second heaven rook bb2 and this is a
more aggressive option because now
you're actually attacking something
rather than just defended yes and it's
nice it's like visually it looks
visually appealing because neither rook
shouldn't take either so like if white
tries to take something then just mate
and meanwhile black just wants to take
on f2 so White's best offensive move
here is to play rook s1 and now black to
move let's see if you guys can continue
with your tactical rampage
yeah rook take us to again kind of
taking advantage of the tactical
situation this rook is overworked it was
defending the espon and defending the
other rook and now now black is actually
threatening mate in three with rift 8g -
and this is actually a really important
position for whites to play the best
move and you guys you were asking
earlier it's black to move and win and
the answer is white can hold a draw a
flight play is a right move in this
position so white white to move plays
really I think the only drawing move
it's basically which rook to take yeah
rook take a - and the point is that you
don't want to trade off both rooks you
want to trade off one rook rotate f2
would be a serious blunder
because after rip take a1 White's forced
to play rook f1 and when both rooks come
off the board this should be a winning
King pawn ending for black so this
position would be winning for black but
the other position if you keep rooks on
the board and you play rook take a two
rook take a two this is a theoretical
draw it's not that easy to draw for
white white still has to work but but
perfectly and especially at like higher
levels this is a relatively
straightforward draw for way
of course yeah almost always how it goes
right yeah question yeah that's very
important point to mention is yeah if
you're down upon in an end game you want
to keep at least like a pair of minor
pieces or pair of rooks because it gives
you more kind of defensive opportunities
and usually if you're going to simplify
down into just a king pawn ending down
upon most of those are decisive for the
side use of the palm yeah and like
there's this kind of famous saying that
all rook endings are drawn which holds
some truth because there's a lot of rock
endings where one sides up a pawn but
still drawn three on five being drawn I
would say and more of the time the five
would win but it's still kind of toss-up
sometimes if you have an active rook you
can have counter play yeah but in this
case like if we go rip take a two all
White has to do is like just kind of sit
back and wait for black to advance and
then eventually pawns will get traded
and black won't be able to promote the
final form so let's move on I think
we're done with seven heaven if I
remember correctly oh this one actually
includes kind of some nice tactic and
then endless seven heaven we're not
entirely done this is White's to move
and I think I might just walk through
this with you
White has like a really nice tactical
opportunity here and the first move is
simply trading Queens now it's important
to note that if you have this in the
game and you're about to play Queen take
d5 it's critical that you see I had a
few more moves to see kind of your task
law opportunity so in this game white
plays Queen d5 kind of knowing what
comes next and the next move very very
strong for white is Knight f5
because now black is in a little bit of
trouble because the threat is rooked 85
there's also ideas of 97 so if this
light moves anywhere 97 for kicking in
the brook so blacks objective here is
not to get for it so okay I want to kind
of give you guys this exercise black to
move don't get Forks so Ruthie I thought
you would say this which work to do
Brooke cd8 unfortunately after rook
takes e5 rook takes e5 you get four so
there is a move here where you don't get
ports you still do them a little bit of
material but it's the best move rook see
two losses of night yeah
rook st8 hello this is going to be a
very nasty for crook cake d5 rift 85 and
you got Forks
let's ricky'll for so rookie it's kind
of off-limits for black any other
resources
yep rook c5 good try but same tactic or
kp5 and you got four all right you guys
want to see the move for black all right
pawn g6 the counter-attack when you're
in trouble and when you're like tackling
in trouble and you can't really defend
look for counter text so in this case g6
counter-attacks tonight it does lose
upon afternoon I take h6 but then black
plays King g7 again carrying or
attacking the knight and the best I can
do here is take nice black and take and
okay this is still really good for like
white one upon and let me actually quiz
you guys here the last move was King
take h6
white to move what's the best move yeah
rip t77 heaven attempting to win another
pawn yeah sure Oh on f7 that is a good
question I think white was probably
scared of rook take so White's left two
pawns right but the problem is then
black gets annoying counterplay blacks
actually winning back upon and getting
back to Brooke so that was actually a
good point though that it looks like
light could grab more material but
especially in these types of rook
endings you want to limit your Compton
counterplay and it was more valuable for
white to just take the knight get the
rope to the seventh before black hand
and now it's nice because if black plays
a move like rook c2 then I can just take
on b7 being up to pawns and still have
their work on the seventh and black
plays defensively is like rook to b8
yeah do you have a suggestion sorry
rooks you want very good bring the other
ropes of 7th and whites like undoubtedly
going to win more plots in the seventh
ring
okay let's wrap it up with one final
tactic we did that one okay so I hope
you guys can kind of absorb the the
themes we saw with first seeing the rook
and pawn and trying to promote the pawn
and then secondly with all the rook and
the Czech meaning ideas I want to wrap
this up with actually a game that I
played just over a year ago maybe about
two years ago now this was a game at
Chicago open I was playing against
Grandmaster Josh Bedell and we've played
actually many times at least four times
over the years and I believe this was
the only game I beat him and as I was
playing this game I was actually like
feeling really sick during the game I
had like buried that headache I could
barely see straight and I was really
lucky because around this point I was
like feeling my worst and then out of
nowhere he just like blundered and gave
me the game for free so me being white I
play rook bg8 and we see kind of a
different sort of different geometrical
concept instead of having my rooks on
the seventh cutting off the king I have
them on the G file but still coming off
the king and still kind of opening up
the same checkmating opportunities so in
this position as black it's very
important that he identifies my threat
and unfortunately for him he did not see
my threat he actually put the poisoned
pawn on a two and then I won the game
very easily with with what move
you up 3g5 uh there's a stronger move
you do want to look for kind of the
mating ideas this is what I want to play
unfortunate black hazard offense
you want play this possible I still
don't see the mating idea maybe x4 here
kind of annoying all right let me show
you guys uh do you see it oh you want to
move this way yeah I know you want to
keep the king cut off with both rooks
three g7 okay let me show you the move
it's rook eight g7 very very important
check because now the king has two
options both of which are bad if the
King moves to h6 rook t6 mates if the
King moves to h8 now the king is far
enough away where we can execute the
same rook t5 idea and this is the proper
this is really the key is to force the
King to h8 and then play with g5 yeah
sometimes when you're sick you can maybe
you're in that different state of mind
where for some reason you should play
better move that's true but anyway
hopefully you guys can take away some
concepts and apply these ideas in your
games so hope you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]